Planeten führen keine
Tagebücher aber wenn doch dann hätte
unsere Erde im Januar viel zu
berichten
Monsterwellen
Kältewellen
killerbeben
Hochwasser plastikflut und vieles mehr
und es beginnt schon im
Dezember
da greifen die Monsterwellen an in
Kalifornien Sturm und hohe Flut bringen
den Pazifik zum
Brodeln das macht nur so lange Spaß bis
sich einer weh
tut zum Glück kommen diese wavewer mit
Schrammen und Beulen
davon andere sind froh wenn sie
überhaupt einigermaßen trocken davon
kommen bis auf 10 m peitscht der Sturm
die Wellen hoch warnt Feuerwehrmann
mcgth und er trifft alle unsere
westlichen Küstengebiete in
Südkalifornien und was hier die
Besonderheit ist die Siedlungen sind
direkt am Strand gebaut denn viele
wollen den Blick aufs Meer genießen aber
manchmal das eben auch
gefährlich Gefahr hin oder
her es gibt Versuchungen denen können
Sie im Surferparadies einfach nicht
widerstehen weiß wellenveteran Kenny
[Musik]
Paul das sind die größten Wellen seit
Jahren auf SAS warten wir ja immer blo
diesmal Muttern ist wohl etwas
übertrieben ein paar Leute mussten wir
tatsächlich
rausfischen und so endete also 2023 und
auf der anderen Seite des Pazifik begann
2024 mit
Schrecken Westjapan erlebte das
schwerste Erdbeben
jahrzehn hier gibt es jedes Jahr
hunderte Beben die meisten spürt man gar
nicht dieses ist
anders meistens hört es ja nach ein paar
Schrecksekunden auf aber jetzt wackelt
und ruckelt es minutenlang
und lässt die Häuser
einstützen vor allem die alten mit den
schweren Ziegeldächern
die oft aus Holz gebaut sind und leicht
brennen tausende sind plötzlich
obdachlos so wie Frau
Kobayashi da drin sind die Wände
zerstört und man kann von einem Zimmer
in das andere schauen ich glaube nicht
dass wir hier noch wohnen
können dum
was überall suchten sie nach
Verschütteten am Ende werden über 200
Todesopfer
gezählt in einem weniger Beben geprüften
Land wären es sicher mehr
gewesen der Wiederaufbau wird Jahre
dauern und Milliarden
[Musik]
kosten
zum Glück gibt es auch ein paar
erbauliche Einträge im Tagebuch der
Erde Schnee im
pandaland das erleben Sie in chin
Südwesten nicht so
oft weißer Januar auch in Soul so viel
Winter wie seit 40 Jahren nicht mehr
und zum eisfisch Festival kommen wieder
100.000
Angelfreunde kein guter Jahresbeginn für
Südkoreas
Flussfische besonders nicht für die
Forellen im Becken der glücksgreifer wer
den Fisch erwischt hat Glück der Fisch
hat
[Musik]
Pech Harbin in Nordchina macht wie immer
das Beste aus dem ganzen Eis haushohe
Skulpturen und jede Menge
ringelpats da kommt man sich auch
menschlich
näher und hat bei Nacht was zum
[Musik]
Staunen
für die Festbeleuchtung sorgt in
Nordeuropa die
Sonne Skandinavien bibbert bei bis zu
-40° na ja nicht alle bibbern mit
frieren ist hier oben
[Musik]
Ansichtssache
Mark versucht mit seinem Truck den
Parkplatz in Demin Iowa einigermaßen
befahrbar zu
halten zur Vorwahl der Republikaner will
er vielleicht gehen sagt er ich weiß
auch schon was ich will ich würde sie am
liebsten alle in die Wüste
schicken
[Gelächter]
lustig Eiswüste haben
sie fürchten das könnte sich auf die
kandidatenkühe
auswirken da kennen Sie aber die
trumpwähler
[Musik]
schlecht die lassen sich nämlich von
keinem Wetter abschrecken wenn es im
Winter schneit dann ist die Welt in
Ordnung wie sagte schon ihr Idol das
ganze Gerede vom Klimawandel haben nur
die Chinesen in die Welt gesetzt um uns
zu schaden
er gewinnt übrigens haush
hoch auch in Europa erinnern sich die
älteren an Schneefall im Winter aber
davon war diesmal eher wenig zu bemerken
z.B in
Tschechien auch in Frankreich regnete es
ohne
Unterlass und so sieht Hochwasser in den
Niederlanden
[Musik]
aus diese unappetitliche Suppe ergoss
sich durch das belgische Städtchen
bouon und auch bei uns verwandelten sich
ganze Landesteile in
Seenplatten der ganze Regen kam übrigens
vom Nordatlantik reingeweht der so warm
war wie noch nie da saugen sich die
Wolken randvoll und Nordeuropa hat es
[Musik]
abbekommen die Böden konnten es nicht
mehr aufnehmen die Deiche sind
aufgeweicht da half nur noch eine große
Zahl von Sandsäcken und solidarisches
[Musik]
anpacken besonders heftig hat es
übrigens die Briten erwischt was
ausnahmsweise mal nichts mit dem brexit
zu tun
hat beim Wetter und beim Klima sitzen
alle Menschen in einem Boot das steht im
Tagebuch der Erde und dahinter steht ein
[Musik]
Ausrufezeichen aber jetzt meint ach das
arme Europa nun geht es unter der muss
nur mal hinüber nach Peru
schauen oder in die andere Richtung nach
Thailand da sieht es nämlich ganz
ähnlich
aus Waterworld auch ein paar Flugstunden
weiter in
Australien und weil die USA so riesig
sind kann man sich sich se dass es auch
da irgendwo wie aus Kübeln
gießt und von den Überschwemmungen in
Sri Lanka wollen wir gar nicht erst
anfangen und selbst auf die Gefahr hin
dass es langsam nervt müssen wir noch
auf die Situation am kongofluss
hinweisen der dank schwerer Regenfälle
seinen höchsten Stand seit 60 Jahren
erreicht hat nur dass vor 60 Jahren noch
nicht so viele Plastikflaschen im Wasser
schwammen aber zum Plastik gleich noch
ein Wort
jedenfalls so schien in diesem Januar
der ganzen Welt das Wasser bis zum Halse
zu stehen außer in Spanien und in
Katalonien da erlebten sie nämlich das
dritte Dürre Jahr in Folge und das
Reservoir das Barcelona sein Trinkwasser
liefert ist nur noch zu 16%
gefüllt und doch
hatten die Spanier akut noch ganz andere
umweltsorgen an der wilden Küste
Galiziens wurden plötzlich unzählige
kleine Plastikkugeln
angespült irgendwo da draußen hatte ein
Frachter ein paar Container verloren die
Pellets könnten giftige Substanzen
enthalten die unsere Tiere bedrohen
warend Umweltschützerin Rodriguez
möglicherweise sind sie auch schädlich
für die vielen freiwilligen Helfer
hunderte ehrenamtliche Müllsammler
bemühten sich entlang der ganzen Küste
die erbsenroßen giftkugeln wieder
einzufangen geduldig wie die
Goldsucher um die Vogelwelt und das
Meeresgetier zu schützen aber auch die
Menschen irgendwann könnte der ganze
Dreck ja in unseren Mägen
landen du
weißt ein Problem hast wenn Männer mit
Staubsaugern am Strand
erscheinen hier hilft allerdings auch
kein Staubsauger mehr vermutlich
schwimmen da auch ein paar kaputte
Staubsauger mit und wer weiß was sonst
noch das Kraftwerk am Fluss dren in
Bosnien muss ich mit einem müllstopper
vor dem ganzen unrad sonst verstopft er
wieder die
Turbinen die Leute hier haben null
Umweltbewusstsein beklagt der furtula
vom cozentrum in
wischegrad alles was am Flussufer
rumliegt kommt irgendwann ins Wasser und
landet dann
hier und wie so oft steht man dann da
und sagt es könnte so schön hier
[Musik]
sein
das gilt auch für
Nordindien indien hat 2023 hinter China
und den USA die meisten CO2 Emissionen
8% mehr als im Vorjahr das merkt man im
Winter sehr deutlich in
AMR da ist nicht mehr der weltberühmte
goldene Tempel zu erkennen obwohl er nur
ein paar Meter weiter im Wasser steht
man sieht ja kaum das
[Musik]
Wasser hier herrscht zum Glück klare
Sicht obwohl die Sache auch nicht ganz
emissionsfrei von statten geht
vulkanusbruch auf Island zweite
Runde die Bewohner von grinderwig
dachten schon sie sein beim letzten
Ausbruch im Dezember davon gekommen aber
der Feuerberg hat sich es noch mal
anders
[Musik]
überlegt und der Winter anscheinend
auch zur Freude der einen und die
anderen
autsch wie so oft kommt der ganze Schnee
eher
ungelegen und viele wären dann doch
lieber woanders kommen aber nicht
weg saukalt ist es in Kanada - 25° sagt
Bademeisterin Anna aber das wird toll
glaube
ich ja
toll auch toll wenn man nur zugucken
darf und nicht mitmachen muss aber es
ist gut für Herz und Kreislauf und noch
dazu ein neuer
[Musik]
Trendsport und so endet das Tagebuch der
Erde im Monat Januar mit einer Gänsehaut
aber einer
gesunden mal sehen wie es
[Musik]
weitergeht